Like he was in a maximum
security penitentiary.
It's like they're never
getting out of there every day.
Every day you're just dealing
with horrible people in
terrible circumstances and
they know that you get to leave.
They know you get to leave,
but you're living with them most of the
day. He goes, yeah, I'm not a prisoner.
He goes,
but my environment is surrounded
by these people is like,
that affects you. It's like, I
never thought about it that way.
I always thought the guards have it. Okay.
It's just a job. Whereas the inmates,
you know well those poor bastards are
stuck in there while you're in there with
them for eight hours a day.
Most of the time you're not
controlling them most of the time.
You just coexisting.
Okay.
Yeah. Who's behind the bars?
Which, which way is behind? Right?
Right there in a cell with a
hallway filled with bars. People,
one person on the other side of each bar.
So are they the same exact thing?
Yeah. And then they're wearing
body armor and fucking,
they have clubs and they're
always terrified that a
riot is going to break out.
You saw Whitey Bulger got killed? He
did. Yeah. When? Yesterday in prison.
Thanks for them. And like first
day, first day hold that guy.
A guy that hates rats,
killed him.
An Italian guy or like a
gangster guy. Really? Yup.
That guide I read, the guy, uh,
is obsessed with hating rats and hating
people that beat women and I guess
Whitey killed women. Wow. This
guy, the first chance he got
Whitey Bulger met a violent end
after a lifetime of brutality.
They, they, they tried to pull
his eyes out of his skull. Whoa.
I don't know if they were
successful or not. The thing I read
didn't make it larger so I could
read that doesn't really say,
what does it say in a three foot
grave near river, not far from Boston.
Pat McGonigal's body laid,
decaying,
undisturbed until his remains are found
20 years later. Part of his pelvic bone,
fractured skull and a decomposed
brain matter or bringing, oh, okay.
This is all the different things
that he's done. Yeah, yeah. No,
he was a horrible fucking killer. What
Virginia dafter it transferred, you know,
I used to train a guy that
was one of his fucking mob.
Henchman hmm. Guy said to me once, he
goes, if you're going to kill somebody,
how would you kill him? I was like,
with my bare hands. He goes, yeah, I go,
I probably hit him in the
neck. It's like, yeah.
Wow. I was like, okay.
That was the end. See,
it's not scary until you find that
that's the end of the conversation.
I was um, I was 19 at the time
and I was teaching taekwondo.
Wow. And I was teaching this guy who, um,
he was friends with a friend of mine who
absolutely worked for Whitey Bulger who
wound up going to jail.
And they told me that this guy used
to whack people. I was like, Oh,
Jesus Christ.
And I was teaching him taekwondo.
He was very serious,
like a WHO's very intense.
Um, I was very aware that there
was something different about him.
I goes very aware,
like cute.
He wasn't just a guy that was
learning for exercise or self defense.
Want to take a little class is
learn a little martial arts.
He was going to use it like he was a guy
that was in case he needed to use it.
You know what I'm saying?
Like there's,
there's a mindset of someone who just
wants to get better at a martial art and
there's a mindset of someone
who's thinking about, okay,
it's going to come down.
I'm gonna Fuck Dude,
I'm right there. Okay.
And I'm going to get to that guy was
like, when he would practice, there was a,
there was a certain amount of focus and
intensity that he had that was palpable.
Yeah. Mobsters need to get better at,
uh, at that type of stuff. You ever see,
remember deniros kicks in, Goodfellas,
those just sloppy. That's straight down.
Just mut. What's this Whitey
Bulger's fate or predict that did it.
He was unrecognizable.
That's it. Go did it. Bam.
Mr Bulges eyes appeared to have
been dislodged from his head,
although it was unclear whether his
attackers gouge them out or they were
knocked out because he was
beaten so severely in the attack.
This information was relayed by senior
law enforcement official who oversees
organized crime cases of,
that's what it was.
It was a padlock stuffed inside a sock.
Oh, that's what they beat him with. Yup.
And they also pulled his
eyes out of his head,
at least in part with a padlock
that was stuffed inside of a sock.
At least two inmates were quickly sent
to solitary confinement after Mr Bolger
was found according to three employees
of the Federal Bureau of prisons.
Wow. Damn. Yeah. Well,
couldn't happen to a nicer guy.
Whitey Bulger. Do you know he won
the lottery twice? Really? Yup.
Not really. Yeah. Scam. I mean,
that was, that was how he,
um,
he would show his income,
so someone else would win the lottery
and they would come to him and he would
like give them the money and they would
give them a lottery ticket and he'd be
like, look, I won the
lottery. That's how I'm rich.
Oh yeah. Yeah. It's dark.
Like they probably would find the
person who won the lottery. You know,
they chase Dana white out of town.
Do you know that? No. Yeah. Yeah.
They wanted money.
They want payment from Dan White and uh,
Dana White got beaten up
by them so severely that he
had like tonight as in his
ears. Fuck yeah. He had a fucking, he
had a jet out of town. He moved to Vegas.
Wow. Yeah. Cause they want her to cut
of the UFC. No, it wasn't the UFC,
it was no UFC back then. He
was like a boxing trainer. Oh,
I forget what he was doing,
whether he's running a gym,
but he had to leave town because of
the mom. That's why he left Boston.
Yeah. It was real, man. I mean
this was all when I was a kid.
I mean I seriously into taekwondo in 1982,
that's when it became like 81 82 that's
when it really became like my whole
life. And that's right around the
time where all that shit was going on.
And then when in 1988,
I became friends with a comedian who
was his brother went to jail for being a
part of why he bolgers mob. Yeah. Crazy.
Yeah.
It was like everybody knew somebody who
was in some way connected to the mob in
some way. You know, I just, one
dude, you want to hear a crazy story?
There's one guy, he's dead now I can
talk about them. His name is Richie,
and he went to jail. Um, while I knew him,
he was arrested for a murder that
I don't think they ever got him on,
but this person who was
killed wasn't just killed.
They broke every bone in his body with
a hammer and kept injecting him with
cocaine to keep him awake.
Yeah.
So he would black out from the pain and
they would inject him with cocaine to
wake them back up again.
And then they would break another bone.
They breaking all of his bones with
a hammer. They cut his hands off,
cut his head off, they cut everything
off. And then when they found, you know,
is broken heap of a body,
he was somehow connected to this guy that
I knew sold coke and this guy had gone
to jail. And uh, I knew
him before he went to jail.
He was another guy from taekwondo.
I knew him before he went to jail.
He was one person. He was a young guy.
I was, I think when he went to jail,
I was 16,
and I think he was 20.
And then when he got out of jail it was,
I was 20 and he was 24.
And he had scars all over his
body where he tried to, uh,
like s sand off his,
his tattoos.
He had tattoos all over his arms and
I don't know what the tattoos were,
whether they were racist or whether
he just didn't want him anymore,
but he had like either acid burns or
scars, like whatever. How were the fuck?
He tried to get the tattoos
off all over his arms.
Arms are covered in scars and um,
he wasn't good.
He wasn't like a,
a talented martial artist,
but he was insanely tough,
like insanely aggressive,
insanely tough. And when you sparred
him, you are fighting for your life,
for your life.
He would come at me and
try to fucking kill me.
I mean fucking kill you.
Throwing looping punches with
every fucking ounce of his being.
And I'm moving around and I'm like,
oh, we're fighting to the death here.
We're fighting. This is
not, this is not sparring.
We only sparked a couple of times before
this, but one time he had cornered,
he trapped me in a corner and hit me with
a fucking bomb on the top of my head.
Just boom, like as hard as he could.
[inaudible] he was a strong guy.
He was quite a bit bigger than me to
Irish guy. I think he was Italian.
Um, and uh, I kicked him in the
head so hard. It broke his cheek,
like his cheek shifted
over. Ah, his, his face.
I wheel kicked him.
So I hit him with my heel and
his face and he dropped down.
He collapsed, went down to is like, Ooh,
like went down like face first,
got up on his all fours,
got back up again, wanted to keep
going. I said, oh Yo Richie, I go,
you got to look in the mirror. I go,
come look in the mirror. And he's like,
oh fuck. I go, yeah, you can't spar
anymore, dude. He wanted to kill me.
He wanted to keep going.
He wanted to keep going after I
basically kicked his face in half. Jesus,
I hit him so hard. It wasn't
a sparring session. It was
an, I'm trying to kill you.
You're trying to kill me session.
And I remember setting them upset
and I'm upset and I'm up. Boom.
And I hit him with that
thing and he face planted.
Most people would've just went out,
but he was so angry and so mean.
He was trying to get up.
It's fucking scary. That was,
I was the last time I sparred with them,
I'm like, we're not sparring anymore,
dude.
I'm not.
Now I'm fighting to the death with
some guy who I'm kind of friendly with.
I was friendly with him. Other than that,
like what was you would never guess.
I remember one time we went out,
it was me and him and these two girls
and they were like real weird. Right.
And uh, you know, this one girl was
like, uh, you know, like Richie,
when are we going to get,
get to get that stuff? I go,
what stuff you're going to get?
And he's like, uh, and she's like,
he's going to get us some coke or you
don't want any coke. She goes, fuck you.
I was trying to tell her she
doesn't want coke. She's like,
that's why I'm here. That's why I'm
hanging out with this guy. Stupid.
That's so funny.
You know,
it was one of the rare times I've
hung out with them outside of the gym.
He told me the story about how he had a
fight off these guys with a broomstick
in jail and how he's beaten these
guys to death with a broomstick,
which is this horrible story about him
being forced to mop up something in a
bathroom and these guys cornered him and
he's just fucking attacking them with
this broomstick and about how
you got extra time for that.
I forget what he went to jail for,
I assume was probably drug related.
I don't remember what it was,
but I remember just being so nervous
about being connected to people like that.
Like knowing people like that from the
gym because there was people like that.
There were always there was wanted to
learn how to fight. So because you knew,
you know, you're teaching martial arts,
you training, there's always those,
those guys would always come in
whenever it was kind of spar. Oh,
scary times. There was no pulling
back. There was no like, if it were,
if you were sparring with some friends,
like I was sparring with like
my friend Lee Roy Rodriguez,
who a good friend of mine who was so
fast as lightning is Puerto Rican guys,
bad motherfucker. But we,
he would not hurt me and we
would spar. We would go hard,
but he would hold back from hurting you.
You know,
like you could trust certain
people while you were sparring.
You knew that was just sparring. There
was other people. It was to the death.
It's terrible. Crazy. No, he didn't.
We did it over a fucking thin, uh,
office carpet on top of concrete.
It was just office carpet on top of
concrete. So when people would fall,
head would bounce off the
concrete. Ah, fuck. Yeah.
It was horrible. Good Lord. As the
eighties, Bro, she was different.
No good. Terrible. So
Darryl Baghdad dead man.